here's what would happen if all the  world's ice melted  sea levels would rise an astonishing 65  meters all over the world countries  sitting in an elevation below this level  would cease to exist big Urban centers  like Buenos Aires Venice and London  would be buried underwater  the world would also lose 90 percent of  its fresh water yeah the melting ice  water would mix with the ocean and  dramatically disrupt the salt levels  many aquatic animals that have evolved  to live in salt water would go extinct  the glacial freshwater stores some toxic  chemicals like DDT and the Arctic  permafrost has as much mercury as  everywhere else on the planet combined  as these toxic chemicals and elements  ended up in rivers lakes and groundwater  they would poison many people  so